good morning John I'm here in Buffalo
New York getting ready to do some
standup comedy which I scheduled
previously and now I'm like this doesn't
feel like a very fun time to be funny
but we'll we'll do it anyway I feel like
I ended up writing a 70-minute long
standup show about cancer for a couple
of reasons first while I was getting
chemotherapy I thought I was going to
want to watch like long form things that
would really capture and hold my
attention which would be great if they
had captured and held my attention but I
was so physically uncomfortable and my
brain was so foggy but I couldn't like
enjoy things like I had no attention
span basically only two forms of content
worked for me sit comes with like a
really large number of laughs per minute
where you're not supposed to like care
about anything that happens like
Seinfeld was perfect and standup was
great like you can start it and stop it
you're always captivated it is always
distracting it I watched so much standup
comedy during gemo I end up going pretty
deep like I'd bring up that I'm doing
commenting people like who's your
favorite comedian and I'd say a name and
they'd be like I haven't heard of them
what about this person I'm like yeah I
get it you have Netflix I don't want to
be like that of course it's just a thing
that happened you know I became a little
snobby about comedy so that's the first
thing like I just watched a lot of
standup the second thing is that like I
broke I I like got some new issues I
think that for the most part to be a
successful comedian you have to be two
things first you have to be very very
very funny uh second though equally
important you have to have some serious
issues of some kind like I didn't
realize how much work it would be to do
standup uh because of course part of the
work is to make it look like it's not
work and to do that work and to hone
that craft like you have to have a
reason and it can't be to make a bunch
of money cuz that's not what happens so
I think I'm like pretty funny and I'm
funnier when I get like a chance to
write it down first but until I got
cancer I was only broken in like normal
little ways having cancer though has
given me some new issues and maybe some
of those issues are healing now or
they're just being buried again I don't
know but I was broken enough and
enamored enough of all of the standup
that I was watching then I was like I
can do that and also I will and I'm
going to work really hard at it and get
a coach and have people help me so
thanks to Sarah aswell and Ben AER for
all of their help with my comedy I
should say that on the stage but it's
not very funny so I don't I needed
something that was very complicated but
very simple like making people laugh
about cancer so this would usually be
the video where I like talk about why I
decided to do standup comedy where I
then say and here my tour dates and come
see me because like I think that it's
pretty good I would like people to see
it it's like 70 minutes of a cohesive
standup storytelling time that people
seem to be having a really good time
experiencing and I think I'd sell a fair
number of tickets uh but I don't think
I'm going to do that there's a couple of
problems first my doctor said that I
should avoid stress if possible because
it can increase the chances of relapse
was a big deal to me while doing comedy
very fun at least while I'm on stage not
relaxing second as I have healed it has
become like less compelling to me I like
I don't know a month ago I was like oh
my God it would be amazing to go on tour
and do like a full month of nights but
now I'm like that sounds bad I want to
be home with my family the way I did
this is I had a standing engagement uh
where every Monday day in my town I did
a show for a couple of months and it was
really great and I sort of worked up
from doing like 15 minutes to doing more
than 70 which is honestly too much and
I've learned so much from doing it uh
not just about doing standup but about
myself and about my relationship with my
disease and with disease in general it
is a really remarkable art form and one
that I think is not considered to be or
treated as art by people who think about
art but it obviously is and is maybe one
of the most important forms of art it's
the only form of art that we evolved a
special noise to appreciate like we do
humor and people
[Laughter]
go that very weird humans are unique in
that we laugh and we cry other animals
do not do either of those things which
is very I don't know that's a thing we
have special specific physiological
reactions for those two things which
yeah I think that means something but I
am doing a TW stop tour while I'm in
Upstate New York I was all already out
here to do a thing at Rochester
Institute of Technology and of course
almost no one will be able to actually
come out and see one of them but
hopefully I will get it filmed and
release it somehow cuz I do like it and
I do think that it's worth people's time
John a quick second part to this video
during the project for awesome we have a
perk called the nerd fighter art perk
and it raises a lot of money every year
the way that it works is that people
make stuff they have to make at least 20
of whatever thing they are making and
then people buy the perk and then you
get something made by another member of
this community you don't know what it's
going to be but it's going to be lovely
it is fun and it is good and if you
would like to create art for the nerd
fighter art perk there is an application
in the description down below you have
to apply before October 27th and you
have to be able to send us the art
before January 15th we're looking for
stuff that is not terribly difficult to
ship so not stuff that's fragile or
large basically you can find out more
about all this stuff at the application
below John I'll see you on Tuesday